[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode Kos
and you know when I'm about to do these
videos I have a thought in mind right
now have a pattern I'm gonna go through
and you know I like to highlight the
statue and stuff like that but mainly I
like to tell my history of the statute
and my history of the character well as
I dev delve deeper into the statue I
realized it really never was about my
affinity for the character its was more
about
how it changed my youth or my perception
of superheroes so without further ado I
give you sideshows Avengers Assemble
line 1/5 black panther now before I get
into the statue itself when I was
younger a heavy spider-man reader right
so it was a character in spider-man
comic books called the white tiger and I
loved that character because martial
arts he had a jade pendant and he was
able to turn into the white tiger and he
was able to fight it was magnificent to
me so I'm reading The Avengers and I
come across the Black Panther so I'm
saying to myself
yo is dude if he's like the white tiger
is on well the white tiger was suspended
and that's not to gloss over this right
because a lot of our characters
sometimes don't depict our people of
color so I'm looking at the I'm reading
a book and I'm like wow kondeh T'Challa
he's nice I mean he's his skills is
incredible and as I read more about him
and they expanded more on the character
I saw the genius of Stanley Stanley I
think never saw color or Stanley was
about the human race and that is
depicted through his diversity
and his his wolf in the characters and I
guess he embodied that with the skin in
the spirit of Marvel Comics that all the
writers and all the artists had that one
unified front where it wasn't
necessarily about color it was about
diversity and culture and inclusion so
without further ado I give you sideshows
assembly line 150 Black Panther which I
thought would be a different video but
getting into the statute when I got it
he has a signature sphere made out of
vibranium and the text detail on a spear
is incredible for 1/5 line a lot of
people don't cover one for flies I do it
costs I think is 460 480 at scishow and
I have the whole Avengers Assemble line
Thor Iron Man Captain America I don't
have the wasp have the Hulk and this
black panther you would think is
simplistic but the level of textures
that is on this character and the
differences in the shades of blue and
the hues of black really brings out the
character is the subtle details within
the statue that allows you to see how
magnificent it is without going over the
top the claws are beautiful seaside show
did take a little liberties here and
there but what I've noticed is they kept
true to a lot of the comic-book
hallmarks of the character which makes
this statue one of the moles
comic-book accurate from sideshows with
them still taking liberties I love the
ears
I love the mass I love the neck chain
with the with the Panther on it which
wasn't in the MCU so this depiction of
the Black Panther is a lot more muscular
and like if you see his on a statue but
he's still sleek and he still can
perform at a high level so I will rape
this statue for me as a sleeper hit
because not too many people I guess was
banking on a statue and I wasn't either
I got a a 1/10 in from einar's Studios
which I was going to do at the same time
with this statue
but after unboxing the statue I realized
at this statute needed its own light
well this is the part in the video where
I'm gonna ask you to like follow
subscribe and also hit the join button
hit that joy button hit that joy button
here get that button hit that button is
right there so you can join the room and
you can see all the videos that we have
in the background that a lot of people
don't get a chance to see follow iron
Lords podcast Sundays at 1:00 p.m. and
also go to Lords of gaming neck you can
see old episodes of Kos episodes of the
last word with loyal Cognito Andy Montes
also hard gaming reviews with addict
addict is phenomenal
I can't say it enough this guy is a
video game Sivan and his reviews on
these hard to conquer games
are impeccable also we have a ton of
reviews and opinion pieces by our
stellar group of writers and also
product reviews we just start a product
reviews so I would like you to go to
check out old-school style his product
review of a new Hewlett Packard Mouse
that should be up at the website today
so always stay collected and I see you
next week when I bring you I guess to
statue that I was supposed to bring you
this week before this one came in and
took over the show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]